and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review the Muppets
oh my god this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
it's time to start the spoilers hey is
this short about Toy Story okay it would
have been a great platform for it but
they kind of burned that bridge but it
was a real good short there's these two
brothers one is named Walter and one is
the catch a Cintiq a plague and they're
excited because they're going to the
Muppet Studios with whoever Amy Adams
played Lucy Walter's excited because he
kind of sort of is a muppet kinda sorta
not really maybe yeah how did the
genetics a network can you just tell
somebody's a muppet if they're born with
a big hole in between their legs
oh wait that's a Kardashian butt up boom
so they go to the Muppets do do but
turns out there's an evil oil tycoon who
wants to rip the studio down I'm gonna
get all that oil and destroyed people's
dreams first the Muppets then little
white ducks named Becky and the work
okay he doesn't see the world but he
might as well it's Briscoe / he has a
plan so Walter booth determined the Frog
and tells it what's happening
Kermit they're ripping down the studio
that's terrible what are we gonna do
raise money through fourth wall jokes
inspired Herman gets back together the
only one missing is Miss Piggy no
seriously she's missing Franca's didn't
that's another story but Miss Piggy says
she won't come back to the show well
it's Kermit admits how he really feels
for her so the blood device for every
Muppet film really why don't you like me
frog it's not me it's you
singing creepin musical numbers some of
them actually connect with what they're
talking about and they finally start to
put on the telethon it's time to Muppet
Show show this is the Muppet Show the
fitment bitmap it okay we know how it
goes but while all this is going on any
atoms he said so the show is going on in
the raising a lot of money and current
society really does Miss Piggy I really
do love you I know this is how we end
every Muppet movie
ready to make the audience cry like
pansies with Rainbow Connection oh yeah
that's right audience its Toy Story 3
but it turns out they need one more act
to get the money they need so Walter
comes out and rinse off the whistling
routine from Malcolm in the Middle
wasn't that beautiful but it turns out
there was a problem with the sign the
actual decimal points I know how that
feels I once thought I had a quarter but
it turns out it was just the nori
anything happens all the time
so Kermit get something from everybody
is like I feel like we won because we
are a family and even if we have to
start at the very bottom again we'll
still be a family will still be great
performers Wow
how very mature holy smokes that is so
touching this this is probably the most
adult message of Muppet film has ever
gotten out to anybody although they went
psycho got hit on the head change is
mine now we can get the studio again
yeah you didn't have the balls
let's do warm-up it was a really really
great show movie thing in fact I want to
be on the Muppets didn't you see my
impressions they'd be great so what if
they're not wearing any skin will just
call it making Muppets there's already a
porn site for it this is just to read
boom sing change come on they'll go to
supporting the mothers to host the
Oscars maybe be fair James Franco was
pretty convincing buckets